those racially tinged attacks on
Democrats come as president Trump touts
a large-scale plan tore us thousands of
undocumented immigrants with final
deportation orders talked to a slow
start you could say immigration
officials delayed raids scheduled to
begin in ten major cities yesterday but
the operation is expected to pick up
this week Manuel Baracus is at an ice
facility in South Florida was more on
the story man well I guess the question
now is how are the immigration activists
getting ready well Gail good morning
they spent this weekend informing
undocumented immigrants about their
rights and what to do if confronted by
an immigration officer now many of those
groups believe that officials may have
delayed those sweeps yesterday's because
of all that heightened publicity around
them but they're warning immigrant
families that the threat is ongoing
immigration activists around the country
are springing into action to help those
threatened by the planned deportation
arrests we know horizon we are organized
the expected crackdown is causing
concern in immigrant communities around
the country and here in South Florida
pastor Howard harden says he's
encouraging his congregation to support
one another I think everybody knows
someone who's affected by this and I
think every church is the same so far
sources tell CBS News activity has been
limited to New York City where
Immigration and Customs Enforcement
agents knocked on doors this weekend but
there were no arrests immigration
officials say about 1 million people in
the country have removal orders acting
ice director Matthew all been said
Sunday the operation targets those who
pose a threat to public safety we are
doing targeted enforcement actions
against specific individuals who have
had their day in immigration court and
have been ordered removed by an
immigration judge but some Democrats say
publicizing the crackdown is the
administration's attempt to instill fear
it's not about getting people who are
security risks and deported
it's about scaring everyone in the
country and it is also about changing
the news some immigrants are seeking
sanctuary in churches including this one
north of Los Angeles this man didn't
want to show his face on camera he's
afraid he'll be arrested in a sweep well
I came here like 10 years ago
more than 10 years now is a very hard
time for immigrants right now with this
administration the American Civil
Liberties Union is trying to block the
mass deportation arrests the
organization has filed a lawsuit
alleging they violate basic due process
procedures and that many of the
immigrants targeted may have not
received the paperwork to appear in
court in the first place
Anthony Manuel thank you